this is my fried rice recipe throwing up
I used to love going to the food court
just to get some fried rice but now that
I'm older I make it at home and it slaps
every time first things first to a
piping Hot Wok we're gonna add some oil
and salted veggies as well as add the
white parts of the scallion next we're
going to add our eggs and let it cook
the key to good fried rice is using day
old rice as a post of fresh rice so that
it can absorb any excess moisture from
there we're going to season with the
following spices on the screen I opted
for low sodium soy sauce but use
whatever you like and this sesame oil
adds a lovely hint of flavor folks pair
this with your protein of choice I
normally do teriyaki chicken and then
you garnish with the green parts of a
scallion folks try it out